at a barbecue to celebrate the end of
the soccer season
1354 hot dogs were served
round the number of hot dogs to the
nearest ten
all right let me just rewrite the number
one thousand three hundred
and fifty four now let's just remember
our places this is the i could write
like that this is the ones this is the
tens this is the hundreds place and this
is
the thousands place now they want the to
round the number of hot dogs to the
nearest 10. so round it to the nearest
10 here
and so right now we have five tens but
in order to round we have to look to the
next smallest place so we'll look to the
ones and we have four ones here and so
because this number is less than five so
because this is less than five we round
down so less
than
five so we're going to round down if you
round down to the
if you round down you get to
exactly five tens or you say one
thousand
three hundred
and fifty we have rounded to the nearest
ten one thousand three hundred and fifty
hot dogs let's do another one
so here we're told the attendance at a
local basketball game was eight thousand
six hundred forty three people
round the attendance to the nearest
hundred and like always pause this video
and see if you can figure that out
let's see eight thousand
six hundred and forty three we wanna
round to the nearest hundred so we go
one place to the right of that and we
say okay is this greater than or less
than is this less than 5 or greater than
or equal to 5 since it is less than 5
so this is
less
than
5. so because of that we round down
and so we were going to round down to
eight thousand
six hundred
so we have rounded to the nearest
hundred eight thousand
six hundred people
let's do one more
the city of joyville has 87 388
residents
around the number of people who live in
joyville to the nearest thousand
so we have
seven thousand three hundred and eighty
eight we wanna round to the nearest
thousand so once again we go one place
to the right we see that it is less than
five and so we're going to round down we
are going to round down to 87
000 that is the nearest thousand
eighty-seven
thousand now since all of the examples
we ended up rounding down let me just
show you what would have happened when
we round up if we had if it was
eighty-seven thousand
well once again if you're rounding to
the nearest thousand you go one place to
the right you say hey this is five or
larger so in this case you would round
up so you would round the thousands up
to 88
in this situation so you go one space to
the right one place value to the right
if that is less than five
then you round down if it is five or
greater you round up